الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله
تعالى فمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من ربك
الحق كمن هو اعمى انما يتذكر ك اولو
الالباب الذين يوفون بعهد الله ولا ينقضون
الميثاق والذين يصلون ما امر الله به ان
يوصل ويخشون ربهم ويخافون سوء
الحساب وقد
سبق الكلام على هذه
الايات قال
تعالى والذين صبروا ابتغاء وجه ربهم
واقاموا الصلاه و فقوا مما رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه ويدرؤون بالحسنه السيئه اولئك لهم
عقب
الدار قوله تعالى والذين صبروا هذا
كله ما
زال في وصف اولي
الالباب اصحاب العقول
السليمه والمقصود هنا
بالعقل هو
العقل الذي له نتيجه
خالده
خالده والنتائج
الخالده لا تكون الا من جراء رضوان الله
سبحانه
وتعالى
كما قال
تعالى فاما ما ينفع الناس في واما ما ينفع
الناس فيمكث في
الارض هذه
النتيجه واما ما ادى نتيجه
ناقصه
مؤقته
كالمباني
والاكتشافات العلميه وال هذه
نتائج
زائله
زائفه لا تبقي صاحبها ولا تخلده
وانما يكون له من حظها في هذه الدنيا وفي
هذه الدار ما شاء الله ثم تزول هذه
النتائج لكن
العقل
الذي يحسب كل ه الحسابات ويفهم كل ه
الفهم ولا يؤدي
صاحبه الى عباده الله وحده دون ما سواه
وتحقيق الغايه التي من اجلها
خلق والعقل الذي لا يعبد صاحبه
لله والعقل الذي لا يحجب صاحبه عن معاصي
الله ولا ترشد صاحبه الى
الحياه والنخوه والشجاعه
والايمان فاي عقل هذا
عقل يكتشف ان
القمر صفته كيت وكيت وان الشمس صفتها كيت
وكيت
و
ان الدنيا هكذا يقول تعالى يعلمون ظاهر من
الحياه
الدنيا هذه هذا الظاهر من الحياه
الدنيا لا يعلمون حتى حقائق الحياه الدنيا
وانما
ظاهرا يعني شيء مما ظهر من الحياه
الدنيا
ف هذا لا يعتبر صاحب عقل في كتاب الله
وجودك
عدمه فقوله
تعالى في وصف اولي الالباب والذين صبروا
الصبر هو حبس النفس هذا اسمه
صبر والصبر في لغه العرب هو
الحبس يقال فلان مات صبرا او قتل صبرا
يعني محبوسا مات في الحبس قتل في
الحبس واما في الشريعه
فالصبر
النفس على طاعه الله وعن معصيه
الله وكذلك عن
التسخط من اقدار الله المؤلمه
والبطر من اقدار
الله التي تسوق
اليه
النعم
فالانسان صابر هو الذي يصبر نفسه على طاعه
الله يصبر نفسه عن معصيه الله يصبر عن
الغفله وقت النعمه
يصبر
على الصبر وعلى حبس نفسه عن معصيه الله
وعن
التسخط
اوقات
ال
اوقات الامتحان والاختبار والابتلاء
والفتن يقول تعالى والذين
صبروا ابتغاء وجه
ربهم
الصبر له
اسباب وكثير من الناس كل كل
انسان له قسط من
الصبر وهذا الص
على
حسب ما يعظمه هذا
الانسان
فمثلا الذي يصبر
على الملك في
مملكته هذا صابر لانه اما خايف من الملك
واما يرجو من عطاء او النيل من
الملك وكذلك الذي يصبر على اذى من هو اقوى
منه فهذا صابر ليش من ضعفه غصبا عنه
صابر الصبر له
اسباب لذلك يقول تعالى والذين صبروا
ابتغاء وجه ربهم يعني
من يعني من اجل نيل رضوان ربهم لا
غير هذا هو الدافع لهم على هذا
الصبر والذي يصبر
لله مع
وجود القدره على الانتقام مثلا وم
وجود
الاستطاعه على عدم
الصبر
فهذا يكون له قسط زائد في الاجر عند
الله
جاء عند الامام
الترمذي باسناد
حسن ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال من
صبر وهو قادر على ان
ينفذه يدعى يوم القيامه على رؤوس
الخلائق حتى يخير من الحور العين ما
شاء الذي يصبر هو قادر على ان ينفذ هذا
الصبر قادر
ينتقم قادر
يضجر
معذور عنده القدره لكن يصبر لماذا ابتغاء
وجه الله ابتغاء وجه
ربه يقول تعالى واقاموا
الصلاه
والمقصود بابتلاء وجه
ربهم الوجه
هنا الله سبحانه وتعالى له
وجه والله سبحانه وتعالى له
رضا والوجه في القران يطلق ويراد به الرضا
ويطلق ويراد
به
الوجه
المعروف الذي هو منن صفات
الذات
وقال اخوه يوسف يخلو لكم وجه ابيكم يعني
انتباهه
ورضاه و
محبته وكذلك الذي
يصبر ابتغاء وجه ربه يعني طلبا لرضى الله
سبحانه
وتعالى وهذا لا يعني ان الله تعالى
كما يقول بعض اهل
الكلام ان الله
تعالى المقصود بالوجه في
القران الرضا بس والا فالله تعالى ليس له
وجه هكذا يقولون نعوذ
بالله الله تعالى وصف نفسه بان له وجه
ونحن نثبت لله تعالى ما اثبته
لنفسه من غير تكييف
ولا تعطيل ولا تمثيل ولا تشبيه هكذا
نثبت الله يقول له وجه نقول وجه الله وما
نزيد على على هيك ما نزيد ولا النقص هذا
هو المطلوب والانسان اذا زاد او نقص عن
هذا اذا زاد او
اخذ مما قال الله والنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وسلم في هذه
الغيبيات فانه لا يزيد ولا ينقص الا من
ايش من
عقله
والعقل لا مجال له في الغيبيات هذه
غيبيات لا يمكن للانسان ان
يقيس الغيبيات على
المشهدا واضح
البطلان ليس
فقط في الاسلام بل اتفق العقلاء على
ذلك الانسان يثبت ما اثبت الله
بس لن يكون اخبر من الله تعالى ولن يكون
ابلغ في الكلام من
الله الله عز وجل يقول والذين صبروا
ابتغاء وجه ربهم الله تعالى له وجه كيف
وجه الله هذا سؤال لا يساله
عاقل
وجهه تليق بجلاله وسلطانه
وعظمته ووجهه لا يشبه الوجوه
سبحانه هل تعلم له
سميا فلا تضربوا لله الامثال ليس كمثله
شيء ولم يكن له كفوا احد الى غير
ذلك لكن لو اجينا وقلنا الوجه فقط المقصود
منه الرضا ما في ما في شيء اسمه وجه الله
عز وجل هذا مثل يضرب مثل رضا الله وجه
الله يد الله لكن ليس له وجه لو قال انسان
هذا
القول يعني لو فلان من
الناس
ليس له فيه مثلا نقص
معين ليست له يد
مثلا ليست له يد ثم ياتي ويقول
فلان له علي
يد يعني له علي منه هل هذا يليق
بالمقطوعية
فلان لا يستطيع
الكلام تيجي تقول والله فلان قليل
الكلام ما يستطيع يتكلم
اصلا هذا اقرب الى
الاستهزاء هذا اقرب الى
الاستهزاء
فلان
ابكم تقول والله فلان قليل
الكلام طبعا قليل الكلام لانه ما يستطيع
الكلام اصلا هذا استهزاء هذا ما هو
بمدح المدح يكون للذي يستطيع
ويختار فعلى كل
حال هذه الصفات التي يثبتها الله تعالى
لنفسه ما ياتي احد يزعم ان عاقل من
العقلاء ينفي ما اثبته الله
لنفسه ولذلك الصحابه ما خاضوا في هذه
الاشياء فهموا ان الله اثبت لنفسه ما اثبت
وما عدا ذلك فليس لنا ان نتكلم بما لا علم
لنا به ولا تقف ما ليس لك به علم يقول
تعالى يقول
تعالى واقاموا الصلاه
اقامه الصلاه غير مجرد
الصلاه لم
ياتي اسم
الصلاه بالاداء الا في
احوال
المنافقين الا قوله تعالى الا المصلين
الذين هم على صلاتهم دائمون فزاد
وصفا ما اكتفى بمجرد اسمهم
مصلون اما المصلي في
القران
هكذا فهذا ياتي ويراد به المنافق الذي
يؤدي الصلاه ولا يذكر الله الا
قليلا كقوله تعالى ويل
للمصلين الذين هم عن صلاتهم
ساهون
وكذلك واذا قاموا الى الصلاه قاموا كسالا
هؤلاء يصلون وليسوا مقيمين
الصلاه المدح في القران لاقامه الصلاه ما
هي اقامه
الصلاه الاداء اداء
الصلاه
بشروطها
واركانها
وواجباتها هذا هو اقامه
الصلاه يصلي الانسان مقيما
وياتي بشروط
الصلاه الوقت ستر العوره الوضوء تمام
الطهاره اركان
الصلاه من القراءه والاعتدال في الركوع
والسجود والطمانينه الى غير ذلك وواجبات
الصلاه وهذه مذكوره في كتب
الفقهاء وقد قد روى البخاري في صحيحه عن
مالك بن الحويرث رضي الله
عنه ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال صلوا
كما رايتموني
اصلي الانسان ياخذ الوصف الذي وصف بها
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في
صلاته يفعل ما جاء به
الوصف احتاج
كتاب يدل على ذلك
يقرا في صحيح البخاري مختصر البخاري يقرا
في صحيح مسلم جميع ما ذكر الفقهاء من صفه
صلاه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فهذه
الاوصاف تدور على ما ذكر البخاري
ومسلم ياخذ كتاب
مثلا زاد المعاد لابن القيم يقرا في صفه
صلاه النبي صلى الله عليه عليه وسلم ويفعل
ما جاء الوصف
به يقول وانفقوا مما
رزقناهم يعني في الخير في وجوه
الخير سرا
وعلانيه قوله مما
رزقناهم
هنا مكتوب في المصحف بخط المصحف الميم
وميم عليها شده
والف اصل هذه من
ما من
هنا حرف جر
وما السؤال من هنا هل بمعنى
بعض يعني يكون التقدير
وانفقوا بعض
ما
رزقناهم كلام
صحي اذا يقول العلء من هنا
للتبعيض التبعيض يعني نحطمه بعض بد
من وقال بعضهم من هنا
لسبب ايش يعني
لسب يعني بسبب ما
رزقناهم ان الله تعالى يرزقهم فكل رزقهم
الله اشتد انفاقهم في سبيل الله
وهذا كلام جيد وجيه
بليغ ان السبب
الدافع لهم على الانفاق في سبيل
الله
انهم
يصلهم من رزق الله ومن نعمه الله ما
يجعلهم
يستحيون من ادخاره
اجمعين فكلما رزقهم الله
رزقوا
الناس مما رزقهم
الله يقول تعالى سرا
وعلانيه السر
والافضل الا في
الواجبات حتى لا يتهم
الانسان يعني الزكاه واجبه هل الافضل اداء
الزكاه سرا ولا علانيه ق لا
علانيه لماذا حتى لا
يتهم وحتى لا تسعى الظنون في
المجتمع واما ما عدا
ذلك من
المستحبات فالسر
افضل فسر
افضل وقوله تعالى سرا وعلانيه يعني حال
كون هذا الانفاق في السر وحال كون هذا
الانفاق في
العلانيه هذا يدل على ماذا
يدل
على الاستقامه ما هي الاستقامه
استواء السر
والعلانيه على طاعه الله هذه هي الاستقامه
تقول ما هي
الاستقامه نقول اذا
استوى اذا
استوى خوفك
لله واستوت حال
حالك في السر والعلا
طاعتك لله ما تنقص في
السر ما تزيد في العلانيه بين الناس وانما
الامر مستوي نقول هذه هي الاستقامه هذا هو
التقوى ما كان من شانك مستويا في السر
والعلانيه هذه
حقيقتك هذه
الحقيقه الانسان الذي يكون على طاعه
الله نفس ما يكون عليه في السر
والعلانيه هذا هو طاعته لله واما ما زاد
على ذلك او
نقص فهذا فيه نظر يقول تعالى ويدرؤون
بالحسنه يدرؤون يعني
يدفعون والدر هو الدفع
الصد ويدرؤون
بالحسنه يعني يستعملون
الحسنه
مد
[Silence]
للسيئات الغير بالسيئه يدرؤون
بالحسنه هل هذا في جميع الاحوال ققول لا
على حسب نقول تعالى وجزاء سيئه سيئه
مثلها لكن في
المعاملات اليوميه التي تكون بين الناس
والامور الغير
مستاهله الانسان يدرا بالحسنه
السيئه وهذا يدل على تواضع
حقيقي واما
الذي يمشي بين المسلمين قلب
مسموم
عليهم اي واحد بطب فيه او بخز لا ينسال له
اياها ابدا تبقى عينه عليه ققول لك البدوي
استد ثاره بعد 40 سنه هذا هذا قلبه
مسموم هذا قلبه مملوء سم والعياذ بالله
وهذا على فكره ياكل نفسه قبل ما ياكل
الناس هذا ياكل
نفسه هذا يدل على
اي وهذا يدل على خبث في القلب وفي الروح
في النفس نفس
خبيثه الناس يتصرفون مع بعض هذا يطب في
هذا
وهذا
والانسان يعفو ويصفح الله تعالى يقول في
العدو الذي لا لا يمكنه الانسان ان ينتقم
منه يقول فاعفوا واصفحوا حتى ياتي الله
بامره العفو
والصفح والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول ثلاثه اقسم عليه
عليهن
ومنها ولا يزداد العبد بعفو الا
عزه عند الله يزداد عزه عند الله
بالعفو
فالانسان الذي
تدفعه وساوس
الشياطين وكل ما اراد ان يحسن جاءه
الشيطان ووسوس وذكره بكل
خطيئه وبكل نقص هو موجود في
الناس فهذا هذا هو عين المرض وهذه من
امراض القلوب وهي تزيد على 30 عند
العلماء في كتاب الله وفي سنه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم مرض الحرص مرض المال مرض
ال ومن هذه الامراض الحقد والعياذ بالله
الحقد من ابرز صفات ابليس انسان حاقد شخص
حاقد
جدا تصوروا كل مئات السنين وادم عليه
السلام راح ومات واندفن ولسه الزلمه حاكت
على ابن ابن ابن ابن ابن الى يوم القيامه
والحقد هذه سمات اهل النار
هكذا يقول تعالى ويدرؤون بالحسنه
السيئه اولئك لهم عقب الدار جاءت الاشاره
اولئك كانهم ابعاد ع
اولئك ولا يلقاها الا حظ
عظيم لهم عقب الدار نقول
تعالى لهم عقب الدار يعني الدار دار
الاخره التي هي
العاقبه لاهل التقوى يقول تعالى والعاقبه
للمتقين
ثم شرع تعالى
في ذكر محاسن
هذه هذا الدار والجنه وسياتي ذكرها غدا ان
شاء الله والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
محمد3
قران الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏destion
people are people
in in
قران people of
intell are those who have a
lasting fruit to their
int
in
‏aed or a thing is ged by usefulness
think
about something is ged by
usefulness we gage things we
give we
give value to things based on
usefulness ‏based on what can do better
me and
so when a person intellect gives him
only a momentary fruit but no lasting
fruit this is considered to be
fruit
‏we
didn't would change the course of
eternity when we look at
true benefit true benefit is that
which is that which transcends death it
goes p the threshold of
death and it sets a person's eternity
onto a trajectory
‏and so person who considered by people
standards customarily to be of intellect
person is
intellect yet his
int bear no more fruits than some
very
isolated worldly gain
‏all worldly g is very very brief and
momentary flash in the
pan a flash in the p really a person
gain in this world
very and so person uses
in
whatever
‏those ints
are and those ints are blunted by
the slightest of ego and
arrogance that person intell can him to
wor
سحى person in do give him that
‏person in do teach
him الله is to be
feared rather his intell is only for
brief momentary things in this world and
his intellect gives him no lasting
fruits that
transcend death this person
intellect basically fruitless in long
in ‏in the long in the scheme of things
person
intellect existence and nonexistence
really
diff and so الله سبحانه وتالى
takes takes into
consideration and so he
mentions
intellect the people of intell are the
believer those
int
‏their intellect able was was guided the
person to
differentiate truly from the rest of the
anals of the world this is a person
in as for in that is good
for
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏they do
not they do not go back orig on their
alliances
andan those
who keep ties with all that which allah
has
commed and those who
‏fear their lord and ex him and they as
well have true fear of jud from
الله he says and
those who are
pent those who make themselves patient
force themselves to be
patient out of seeking the pleasure of
their lord
قران examples but patience really is in
three main
things
patience is restricting a person
s either a person is patient in
do
in pr
‏re to the
dee b and so a person who is patient
every human being if they survive in
this world have some level of
patience as a minimum everybody has to
have some level of patience some
semblance of
it people are patient for different
reasons some people are patient ‏for
paycheck some people are
patient
for so that they don't lose a position
some people are
patient
because they want to in harmony with
someone or etc they want to gain
something or they don't want to lose
something however specifies those who
are
‏reas
pleasure establish prayer and from that
which we have blessed them with they
give in both secret and
public and he gives a
final
attb
parad
‏with good
ev when they
are and this is in
immediate petty
everyday things this is the point of
this the point of this is is not in
every every every single
situation is
it appropriate for a person to pardon
another not always
‏but in everyday circumstances unless
you have
been
clearly oppressed or wronged by
someone in a finite definable
way
just getting on someone's
nerves a person annoying you or a person
being rude or a person ‏this is not
worthy of person's anger it's not worthy
of a
person and it's certainly not worthy of
a
person
revenge and
so a person who cares around these
things in heart this is
not of the people of
inis his
own
‏evil with
a people don't treat him as he to
be treated in
every run of the m
things this person does not jump
to
retribution and
reng and holding deeply seed deeply
roed timeless
‏you know
timeless deeply
seed deep seed deeply roed timeless
venom in their heart someone sl them
incre
is الله سبحانه
وتالى ‏has blessed with fa true
fa we will end there
for ان شاء الله والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
ا